around around easiest like obviously
with the injury MC mix sustained injury
making sure the legs not hurting him
make sure that he's healing good we
decided the cardio is gonna be boxing
it's not putting any pressure on the
knee by building up that cardio we've
lost the full stone now in less than a
month talk to those results results
speak for themselves that's the guy
right there
yes'm so yeah it's just getting around
the problem like I had when the
operation and we spoke I were going to
playfully on hold and models like we
can't play Nick no hold so we've just
adapted to it but to be honest have an
erection last week good because I'm
eatin well that I'm recovering good lots
of stone so obviously got a long way to
go I think I was wearing the same vest
on our first session seeing this but the
best is super bag you know the best bag
here is for the rest of look burning
down the waist size down a white size in
less than a month yes there's a lobby
28-day exactly so yeah I was waving them
up this is by the end of this week we'll
probably be down another two to three
pounds and then again it's consistency
making sure that every single week we're
doing something different working the
body differently that's all day
well again three four
[Music]
Marvin how's it been working with me do
you know I had expectations but we had a
very long conversation before we even
started yeah
so from that I knew that your drive was
not gonna be out doing your performance
yes I knew that your performance would
show what you're doing you worried at
the beginning that I'd give up and then
you'd have counseled all your other
clients do you know what I actually
wasn't worried because I felt like you
held yourself accountable and because of
that reason because you put it out there
socially I knew you had to I do a lot of
challenges financial challenges probably
challenges a lot of people keep telling
me I need to go six-pack as a challenge
it's hard to get motivated you're so
busy at work I decided you know what I'm
looking for a full-time because I do
things either in full or not at all I'm
looking for a full-time personal trainer
to train me to travel with me get me
ripped or document the whole thing
travel on the road with us come around
our houses make sure that we are eating
the right foods working out everyday
full-time position if you're interested
Kimia I just knew that the way my
approaches in how we do exercise I could
make it fun for you yeah thank you it's
really interesting cuz that's how I
found a thought that I was going to
dread the sessions and I used to dread
the sessions yeah I used to before I
knew what the sessions were yeah like
because the first session was hard and I
was but now I actually look forward to
the sessions and now if I haven't had a
session if we if it's luck of something
whatever I'm like where's Marvin at man
yeah you've rang me again are you free
like you basically said that are you
free to those that I'm not free you've
done like five sessions of the week you
need a break but the fact of the
marriage you've got that
Dornan release now where is become a
part of your lifestyle and that's
exactly what this month from the first
session for today's session was about
yeah he's about that behavioral change
and that pattern of going I'm not not
I'm supposed to work out today I want to
work out today yes you're there now yes
I only took a month they say it takes
six weeks to build a habit and form a
habit you've already got it yeah for me
I just need to make sure I lost a stone
which is gray I've kind of lost the big
belly it's still a little big but it's
you know I'm slimmer ice known is it
when you put like 14 pounds is a lot
yeah it's a lot of weight and you can
see it for your clothes you can see in
your face and people are commenting
saying oh my god how much weight is he
lost but this is just one stage of this
Jenna the big thing for me is that how I
feel this is not only possible but
sustainable because I feel I don't feel
like I've got a really hard crazy month
and now I'm just like oh how long he's
gonna last and I've lost a stone and
it's about to get put back on I feel
like I have a new I have a new life in
terms of fitness and health yeah and I
think that the biggest thing for me is
the emotional and the moral support from
everybody yeah so having obviously not
mostly from you know thanks to you know
obviously because you're actually coming
with me you're messaging me every day
asking me what I'm eating but also in
the positive way not in a oh man you
know you had that I that's terrible more
just in a common man yeah we want to
give it you know the one thing I do want
to say what a lot of people there's a
lot of people out there that are
watching this and have an understanding
to all these fad diets and things they
do now you knew from the beginning I was
like no I'm not going to micromanage you
because I need you to manage yourself so
that you can sustain this because eating
it's not about going let me get these
shakes and let me do that and let me eat
this only one meal a day I'm like you
have any meals every day like five seven
some more meals
loads of food but you're losing weight
because we're good it were building up
your metabolism yeah and I mean a lot
yeah a lot of meat yeah organic steaks
yeah exactly that's true that's your
go-to meal now is your steak but then
when you start to have the steak and
eggs breakfast and things like that you
just want to be able to have something
that you enjoy
you wake up and go oh gonna have some
oats today or I'm gonna have some scram
it's like the fact that you can get to
enjoy being healthy that's what I wanted
you to do is enjoy the process yeah who
just happened to support but I think the
moral support from I mean even the
videographers you know these guys as a
team battle team Lakshmi review hard
come on say you know and then I've got
my wife my family support you making it
easy for me because for me everything
it's all about convenience I think in
2020 a convenient sells yeah and the
thing that's hard is you know you go for
a run and then you've got to get your
clothes and wash them and then you've
got to get this and this special food
and this is and it's just like it's just
so inconvenient whereas whereas with the
sow that we've got now we've got a gym
right next to the office yeah I got my
clothes at the gym yeah I've got the
I've got people Amanda helping me out
Emelia support and they're helping me
out and she's also working out and doing
stuff so it's just like and I always say
this environment is always stronger than
well power yeah you can you can have
willpower and say I'm gonna do it but
I'm gonna do it all we're gonna do it
when you're in an environment with
people suddenly just becomes it just
becomes fun it's the exact same for
business when you're trying to make
money if you're the only person or all
your family going well we'll see be
careful yeah then how are you supposed
to make money whereas when you're in an
environment of people all making money
all in business so late just becomes fun
yeah well that's what we got to do
because it's like like you said
environment team that's what we are so
yes making sure the team is all getting
involved cause anything we're doing
something that's Barry and so so what
people are asking me what exactly have I
been doing like whatever Benny in
whatever been doing to lose the stone in
a month it was actually just less than a
month I mean yeah yes I'll stone in a
month what I've been doing so what would
you say well what we've been doing
really I think the first three weeks was
very heavy cardiovascular but what we
did was we we worked pretty much every
muscle we didn't I wanted to activate
everything had been dormant for years
that you hadn't been using so I wanted
to make sure we built up your cardio
made sure that your bodyweight exercises
were on point to where we then we wanted
to overload we then got to the weights
and then we did a way to program so
we've started a weights program the only
difference was you're naturally strong
so I didn't realize that you were going
to be as strong as you asked and we've
had to progress weight
quicker than I expected I thought we
were where we are now I thought we'd
have two months down the line that's the
weights we'd be using but we're actually
ahead of schedule and where we want to
be good so in terms of light now and how
we've worked it out we've just basically
been doing from the game cardio strength
conditioning what we read new food was
food wise it's just been about like
making sure you had the understanding of
when to eat what's he and when not to
eat and as long as you understood those
principles and that's what we did so we
said you have to eat breakfast because
you're someone that skips breakfast so I
was like no you've got to eat breakfast
cause it's got to make sure your body is
basically digested and you build your
metabolism for the day think of what I
said to you it's like a steam train the
steam train can't go faster if you're
not giving it coal yeah so the
difference was we had to make sure you
had the right food coming in the thing
is there's so many different theories
around food and some people say don't
eat meat some people say do it me some
people say intermittent fasting the
morning eat in the morning and there's
so many different stuff and I kind of
feel like sometimes there's an overload
of information on the yeah where you can
get to the point where you get confused
and then when you get confused you do
nothing yeah so what I've kind of
decided to do is just to just forget
everything that I'd previously knew
about nutrition and stuff just Park it
and I've just decided I'm just going to
just do what you tell me to do yeah and
because because because me personally I
came to the conclusion actually yeah
skipping breakfast it's not a bad thing
and here's why but I just you know what
I must give you a lot and told me to do
tells me to do but the proof of the
pudding is in the eating and no pun
intended and you know I've lost a stone
and you seem pretty confident that I
will lose another stone in probably the
next couple months or so yeah I feel
like I said to you what happens is
you'll slow down in my course you can't
lose a stone every month otherwise L
would that be a phase dude if we did
that I'd be something to write about but
to me I want it to be done gradually so
then by the time you get to your
destination you can't come back as fat
fat diet in you get there quickly you go
back faster and it's not I don't feel
like I've been on a diet I feel like all
I've been doing
it's I've been cutting down massively on
carbs not creating out carbs yeah it's
create down low carbs yeah so what I'm
generally having is in the morning I'll
have
some Weetabix oh I'll have some egg on
toast
yeah and then in the afternoon or I have
a wrap
yeah maybe a tuna wrap chicken wrap or
an advocate I got a rack on your
favorite right there in the evening I'll
have some steak a nice lamb steak with a
bit of mint sauce or a bit of beef steak
always organic from Waitrose yeah no
carbs
I'll have loads of green beans carrots
and not to mention as well your water
intake is way higher than its yeah you
never train this much water before I do
that to you when you're hungry as well
sometimes just drink across the water
like when we met and we started doing
that training together a month ago I was
like how I am what how I'm talking now I
would not have said this six weeks ago I
know that different place and I was just
thinking you know what I'm making so
much money my family a half day yeah
life is good yeah who cares if I'm on
know what you may be otherwise you know
I think I look good yeah and I'm all
right but now I have a totally different
mindset and I think that's a big a big
part a big part too as well moving
forward then what can people expect to
see over the next few months or the next
over throughout the year well we're
going to be doing some really great
challenges we're going to be going to
we're gonna do an excursion yes yeah so
we're gonna do it calling me mountain
lion so that was your influency like
let's do Bend never says that I don't
really like mountains but you know what
let's do it so we have to do been
nervous we're going to a few and
specialized gyms to get some special
workouts for some great people that have
agreed to do the workouts with us I will
be working out with you so you'll get to
see me get boosted for once which would
be quite funny and throughout the year
we're just gonna just make it a show
more of the food give them a bit more
tips and hints and we're going to be
doing and like just let people know just
why the change is happening because
between everybody's eyes nobody's
looking it's like it might seem to them
like you've lost weight too fast but we
say but yeah this is consistency over
seven days a week every day of the week
yeah like it's not just like dipping in
and out no no it's pretty sick respect
you're awesome to work with thank you
bro same likewise if you look at the
first video tour we did our actual first
workout you wouldn't believe the changes
not just physically men
Tooley everything he is completely
transformed in every way that I was
hoping he would I was trying to get a
six-week habit going but we've already
started that four-week habit trends
going now that behavioral change started
pretty much immediately from when I came
in on the third day he knew that he's
committed to it he's pushed through and
now less than a month later he is a
stone down so I'm already about four to
five pounds ahead of schedule but I know
it's going to slow down so in the next
months coming up what I'm planning to do
is basically build a bit more muscle so
we're gonna be hitting the gym a bit
more doing a lot more overload
progressive overload I'm gonna be
logging the weight so we can always get
better a bit a bit bigger and then we're
gonna be getting back into the cardio
because now cardio-wise he's in a great
place it's just that with the operation
that he's had we've had to make sure in
the next coming weeks that's got to heal
and once that's healed we'll be in a
position then to go back to cardio but
for now we're still boxing still getting
a good sweat getting good calories out
we usually burn between on an average
about maybe 500 to 700 calories a
session which he's already offsetting
with his breakfast and weekend making
sure that we've got an input versus
output which I always talk about is
making sure that you're not eating over
the amount of calories your body needs a
day so moving forward in the next coming
months you're going to see more weight
loss more fat loss and you're going to
see some great challenges on the way as
well I know you guys already
see
[Music]